Andthen
[Music]
and even the voters of this monster opened
their eyes, they understood our country is being
ridiculed in the world our country that has
always been champion and vaccine is not
managing to vaccinate has 16 percent of the
population vaccinated with a second dose
especially we have allowed it with  that
this citizen would turn them into the
president of the republic and the
consequences that we are seeing today
that are mainly translated into this
absurd number of deaths from the pandemic
due to carelessness how this
serious matter was treated here in Brazil, right
It is
and it has to be here in the  street of the
day if the government is genocidal it is
killing more than people it is running out
Planalto Amazonia corruption the
genocide and all the
horrible things that are happening it is
necessary to be on the street to fight and for
us to be able to have a future there is an
Amazon in the  future and have life so
vaccine like this and outside bolsonaro people
be aware that we live in
a government that denies  tionism there it goes up it
was supposed to have arrived a long time ago
many families lost people
relatives friends and
Andthen